hey 42 here for most of human history
language was a solely verbal form of
communication
and whilst we don't know exactly when
humans first spoke
estimates ranged between 50 and 150 000
years ago
we do know that the written word came
much later
perhaps just five and a half thousand
years ago
but recent times have seen the invention
of a completely new
form of communication one that most of
us use every single day
not the written word but the typed word
typing is becoming so ubiquitous in the
modern world
it's in danger of killing off
handwriting altogether
cursive that's joined up writing to you
and me
was removed from the united states core
curriculum in 2010
with the ability to use a keyboard and
mouse
added in its place not long after this
decision caused quite a bit of stir at
the time plenty of people think joined
up writing is a basic life skill
but then again when was the last time
you wrote a letter in place of an email
or text message
with the typed word very much here to
stay then
our keyboards have quietly become some
of the most important tools we interact
with
on a daily basis but as we type out
essays and
do battle with internet trolls few of us
ever bother to consider where the
familiar layout
of keys that lies beneath our fingertips
actually came from
or if that layout actually makes any
sense
so if your typing speed is so slow it's
making you miss deadlines
obliterating your street cred or
bringing shame to your entire family
i'm about to tell you exactly who's to
blame
christopher schultz was a 19th century
printer who decided to try his hand at
politics
it's fair to say he did pretty damn well
at it too he served in the wisconsin
state
legislature where he led the movement to
abolish capital punishment in his state
and he was eventually appointed by
president abraham lincoln himself
as collector of the port as in the place
ships dock to load cargo
not the delicious fortified wine
scholes's new role which was to collect
import duties
didn't just earn him more commission
than a toilet roll salesman during
a pandemic it freed up his time to do
what he loved best
invent things scholes had spent much of
his life dabbling in
inventing but in 1864
he finally secured a patent for a page
numbering machine
something guaranteed to earn him kudos
with other printers
then fellow inventor carlos glidden took
a look at this machine
and made the inspired remark that
if it could print numbers why not
letters
shoals and glidden along with other
letter printing enthusiasts
immediately set to work in their small
milwaukee workshop
to create a machine by which a man may
print his fort
twice as fast as he can write them not a
bad endeavor
given that people back then were still
messing around with inkwells and leaky
fountain pens
after four long years tackling
uncooperative spools
rollers and levers the industrial
foursome's efforts finally paid off
when they secured a patent for what came
to be
the world's first commercially
successful typewriter
but it was a very different beast to the
one loved by hipsters and eccentric
aunties today
it looked more like a musical instrument
than a writing device
with its elongated ivory and ebony keys
laid out exactly like those on a piano
the letters on those keys were arranged
in alphabetical order
and like bob marley it was rather
partial to jamming
presumably shows hoped his customers
liked jamming too
and judging by the product's early
successes it seems
they probably did because after shipping
out their first
piano style typewriter to a mr edward
porter
of porter's telegraph college in chicago
the orders started flooding in
but as a quick glance it's the nearest
keyboard will tell you
the modern day descendants of scholes's
typewriter
look nothing like pianos and unless
you're some kind of sociopath
the keys won't be in alphabetical order
either so
what happened your keys may not be in
order but your balls will be when they
are
shaven and nicely centered with
manscape.com
who've currently sponsored this video
lately i've been using manscape's brand
new refined cologne which has the most
incredible scent
it's light and approachable but with a
pleasing masculine scent
ideal for the refined gentleman that you
are
refined is calming and inviting on the
nose
with a light citrus burst before
settling into the anchoring notes of
vetiver
eventually landing on a woodsy masculine
finish
it's hypoallergenic cruelty free dye
free
paraben free and 100 vegan
i love the look of the bottle it makes a
statement on your dresser or in your gym
bag
and it's the perfect accompaniment to
manscape's
incredible all-in-one performance
package kit which includes the new
lawnmower 3.0 it's waterproof
so you can maintain your lawn in the
shower and with
advanced skin safe technology to help
reduce any
nasty nicks and cuts the performance
package kit also includes the crop
preserver
ball deodorant and the crop reviver ball
toner
and two free gifts the shed travel bag
i love this thing and the very fetching
manscaped anti-chafing high-performance
boxer briefs go to manscape.com
today and get 20 off plus
free international shipping plus two
free gifts when you use the promo code
42 at manscape.com your balls
and body will thank you well
we know from an article published in
scientific american
that by 1872 scholes had swapped the
keyboard's original layout
to the decidedly counter-intuitive
arrangement
we used today the so-called qwerty
system
but the million-dollar question is why
did he feel the alphabet had seen its
best days and was on its way out
was the new layout inspired by a
particularly heavy night on the opium
was he just a bit of a knob the most
popular explanation is that shoals had
to redesign the keyboard
in response to the mechanical failings
of those early typewriters
if a user quickly hit keys with type
bars next to each other
the delicate machinery would jam and so
scholes needed a way to slow typists
down
makes sense but this theory is not
without its critics
if it were correct after all the qwerty
system
should create the maximum separation of
the most
common letter pairings in english you'll
see from your own keyboard
that h and e and a and n
are separated but t and
h the most common letter pairing of all
are fairly close to each other whilst e
and r
the fourth most common are directly next
to each other
and here the plot thickens even further
scholes's typewriter prototypes had yet
another keyboard layout that was only
changed immediately before
he filed the qwerty patent and if that
layout had been put into production
i'd be telling you about the cuadoti
keyboard
in other words one where e and r are not
next to each other
and where punctuation can be found mixed
up amongst the letters
this could suggest scholes wanted to
slow typist down after all
but what caused his last minute change
of heart
the answer oddly enough lies with
firearms manufacturer
e remington and sons in one of the more
peculiar cases of product
diversification
remington decided the typewriter
cutting-edge technology at the time
was the perfect complement to its bread
and butter line of
rifles and revolvers the man behind this
surprising move was remington executive
henry benedict who'd received a
typewritten letter from scholes
and had been so impressed he immediately
offered his company's manufacturing
expertise
which was an especially surprising
result given
scholes's typewriter could only print
capitals at that point
so his letter probably came across a
little
shouty to scholes's delight remington
signed a contract to manufacture his
machine
straight away but then their engineers
produced a prototype
with a different keyboard layout they'd
switched
the r key with the full stop scholes was
understandably angered by their impudent
cheek
and demanded the r key be put back in
its rightful position
remington agreed and released their
number one typewriter
in 1874. it seems the slow typing theory
might still be true
at least when it comes to scholes's
original intent
but for those of you unconvinced here
are two alternative theories
one is that the keyboard was adapted to
suit its very first
users remember porter's telegraph
college
their telegraph operators supposedly
found the alphabetical arrangement
to be inefficient for translating morse
code
and so the theory goes qwerty was
designed to meet their needs
with letters that had similar morse code
designations placed closer together
another theory is that qwerty derives
from a flamboyant sales technique
as it would have allowed the remington
salespeople to
quickly peck out typewriter using only
the top row of letters
to dazzle potential customers a
technique guaranteed to win over the
stingiest of technophobes
i'm sure you'll agree the theory sort of
makes sense
and it does seem a little too
coincidental
that all of the required letters can be
found on the top row
but unfortunately there's no hard
evidence to back this one up
one thing we do know is that the qwerty
typewriter
which initially left buyers unimpressed
due to its high cost
and tendency to break nonetheless
secured its position in the marketplace
thanks to a stroke of marketing genius
remington decided to offer free or
discounted typewriters with their
touch typing courses that's basically
just typing in 2021
but back then people mostly used a hunt
and peck
method still favored by grandmas to this
day
the course helped type is to memorize
the position of the keys
which allowed for greatly improved
typing speeds
but here lies the truly ingenious thing
about this course
the touch typing skills it taught were
only ever relevant to qwerty keyboards
making it virtually impossible for
participants to use a different layout
later on remington literally
programmed their layout into the brains
of their typists
creating a kind of qwerty zombie horde
who infiltrated private business
colleges prestigious universities
and even the young women's christian
association
according to remington at the time and
why would they lie
moving to a non-qwerty model could cause
typists words per minute
to go down by as much as 80 percent
placing employers in a bit of a tight
corner because
even if they wanted to buy a different
model they'd have to take a huge hit to
productivity to do so
and that's pretty much how the qwerty
typewriter
won the battle for dominance in the
1880s
by 1890 there were more than 100
000 qwerty keyboards in use in the us
alone a well-deserved pat on the back
for shoals and remington then
but has qwerty remained a good thing for
society
the short answer is probably not the
designs that made life easier for
telegraph transcribers and
touch typists back then are more or less
irrelevant now and several other
keyboard layouts have claims to be
far more efficient one particularly
fierce critic
an educational psychologist called
august dovrak
believed so firmly in the shortcomings
of the qwerty design
that he had a team of engineers test a
whopping
250 keyboard variations
and concluded that qwerty was one of the
worst arrangements
possible harsh words but he backed them
up
by pointing out many of its letter
combinations required
awkward finger motions some common
combinations had to be typed with the
same
finger and too much typing was done with
the left hand
which everyone knows is a tool used only
by devil worshipping witches
then again dothrak did have what you
might call
a conflict of interests in 1936 he
patented an
alternative to quality the dovrak
simplified keyboard
which he claimed was easier to master
faster to use and gentler on the hands
the most common letter pairings were
typed with alternate hands using the
strongest fingers
and the right hands did most of the work
with such
great apparent gains people started to
take an interest in the dovrak keyboard
in the 50s
and a few businesses and government
organizations
even considered retraining their typists
but in the end it didn't take off later
experiments showed that
a whole range of designs allowed similar
typing speeds to doverak
when typists were fully trained
suggesting that
all of his careful design principles
might have had little to no effect
after all and then there's the not so
small issue
of retraining people on a mass scale to
use a different keyboard layout
it should only take about 52 hours
according to dothrak himself
but as we've seen he's probably not to
be trusted
and anyway he wants to book time off
work for a typing holiday
if you do fancy having a go just for the
hell of it though you
absolutely can linux windows and mac all
offer the option to switch to a dothrak
keyboard layout
or you could try the more modern version
colemag which claims to be far more
ergonomical than qwerty
since becoming the de facto standard the
qwerty keyboard
has seen off dozens if not hundreds of
competitors in this way
it's transferred seamlessly from
mechanical typewriters to computers
to touch screens and it seems to be
ubiquitous
wherever the latin alphabet is standard
it seems that
as a society we're locked into qwerty
despite
its shortcomings we teach kids to use
qwerty
because it's everywhere and why is it
everywhere
because we teach kids to use it but
qwerty isn't the only technology to
stick around
past its cell by date far from it
we think of technology as being
something progressive that
adapts to our existing needs as well as
needs we don't know even have yet
but sometimes things don't quite work
out that way and
we find ourselves locked into using a
sub-optimal product
in fact this phenomenon is so common it
has a name
path dependence it's when a feature of
the economy isn't based on
current conditions but rather a sequence
of past actions
or requirements in a nutshell it's a
theory based on the assumption that
history matters one classic example of
path dependence
is the videotape format war a period of
intense competition in the late 70s and
80s
between betamax and vhs both
technologies solved
the same problem how to store
information
efficiently on a cassette tape and
many expected sony's betamax to win it
offered better image and sound quality
than jvc's vhs
but sony focused their marketing on time
shifting
their ads featured headlines like watch
whatever
whenever highlighting the fact that for
the first time ever
tv footage didn't have to be watched
when it went
on air jvc on the other hand cunningly
focused their efforts on getting cosy
with the new video rental industry
when that market grew vhs dominated its
titles
the stores gave more shelf space to the
slightly more dominant brand
which then dominated even more this
created a bandwagon effect
manufacturers switched to vhs because
they expected it to win the battle
locking consumers in even further
finally sony in a surprising act of
moral superiority
refused to let pornography companies
license their technology for mass
production
which meant that nearly all porn
released on video
used vhs format and that
as you might expect was the final nail
in the coffin for betamax
vhs won the video format war despite
being an inferior product and
betamax wasn't seen again until a guest
appearance in the mighty boosh
of course both betamax and vhs went on
to be replaced by dvd
then blu-ray and finally digital
streaming
and it isn't difficult to imagine that's
a similar fate
awaits qwerty it seems that no other
keyboard layout will be able to replace
it
but will keyboards themselves become a
thing of the past
in the not too distant future tap for
instance
is a one-handed gadget that fits over
your fingers
kind of like rubbery brass knuckles and
connects wirelessly to your smartphone
you then tap your fingers in certain
combinations to create letters
and you could theoretically do this
anywhere
on a table your arm somebody else's arm
it's supposed to free you from keyboards
entirely by acting as a
go anywhere typing interface other text
such as predictive typing software is
also starting to make the keyboard less
essential
google's smart compose for instance
offers simple
and sometimes hilarious ai powered
suggestions and responses it's already
saved people from typing
over a billion characters each week
enough to fill the pages
of 1 000 copies of lord of the rings
there's even a possibility we won't need
any kind of input interface at all
norable is a massachusetts-based startup
that's working on a way to
type simply by thinking
their method isn't exactly subtle as it
uses an electro-dotted headband
to track your brain activity but machine
learning helps it figure out which
letter you're trying to select
and anticipate the one you'll want next
imagine the fun that
drunk you is going to have with that one
so
if qwerty is ever replaced it's looking
like the winner
will be a completely different type of
input altogether
not just another keyboard layout but
there's another way qwerty has affected
society that's perhaps
a little bit more disturbing than
inefficient typing
and carpal tunnel syndrome in 2012 two
psychology researchers
kyle jasmine and danielle casasanto
demonstrated something they called
the qwerty effect they figured out that
words using a higher proportion of
letters from the right hand side of the
keyboard
tend to be easier to type that's because
the qwerty keyboard is asymmetrical
meaning there are more letters on the
left of the midline than on the right
weirdly enough they discovered we
associate these
easier to reach words with more positive
emotions
and that because of this qwerty may have
influenced the emergence
of new words such as lol and even
our choice of baby names from around
1990 which the team defined as the dawn
of the modern keyboard era
invented names had a much higher
proportion
of right side letters than popular names
of the previous three decades
and existing names with more right side
keys
names like noah sophia and liam
were also increasingly favored the
researchers even went on to advise that
people responsible for naming new
products
brands and companies might do well to
consult their keyboard when choosing the
right
name pun intended this turned out to be
sound advice
four years later another study carried
out by david garcia and marcus streimer
found that people do indeed prefer
products and video titles
spelled with more right hand side
letters
the pair gathered huge amounts of data
from websites like amazon
imdb yelp youtube and even pornhub
and found that content with more right
side letters
was on average more highly rated by the
audience in terms of reviews
likes and ratings in other words qwerty
is actively shaping our choices as we
filter language
through our fingers so next time you're
kicking back to enjoy the latest 42
video
doing some late night shopping or
engaging in some
self-love send a virtual high-five to
christopher scholes
after all he's probably playing a more
active role in all our lives
than many of us would have ever imagined
thanks for watching
thanks again to manscape.com for
sponsoring this video
don't forget to check it out using the
link in the description below